it always helps me to see a lot of
examples of something so I figured it
wouldn't hurt to do more scientific
notation example so I'm just going to
write a bunch of numbers and then write
them in scientific notation and
hopefully this will cover almost every
case you'll ever see and then at the end
of this video we'll actually do some
computation with them to just make sure
that we can do computation with
scientific notation let me just write
down a bunch of numbers and say I have
zero point zero zero eight five two
that's my first number my second number
is seven zero one two zero zero zero
zero zero zero zero zero zero
I'm just arbitrarily stopping the zeroes
the next number is zero point zero zero
zero zero zero zero zero zero I'll just
draw a couple more I have to keep saying
zero that you might find that annoying
five zero zero the next number right
here there's a decimal right there
the next number I'm going to do is the
number seven two three the next number
I'll do I'm having a lot of seven zeroes
to point six and it's zero point six and
then let's just do one more just for
just to make sure we've covered all of
our bases let's say we do eight to three
and then let's throw some an arbitrary
number of zeroes there so this first one
right here what we do if we want to
write in scientific notation we want to
figure out the largest exponent of ten
that fits into it so we go to its first
nonzero term which is that right there
we count how many positions to the right
of the decimal point we have including
that term so we have one two three so
it's going to be equal to this so it's
going to be equal to eight that's that
guy right there 0.5 two so everything
after that first term is going to be
behind the decimal so 0.5 two times 10
to the number of terms we have 1 2 3 10
to the minus 3 another way to think of
it this is a little bit more this is
like 8 and 1/2 thousands right each of
these
thousand so we have eight and a half of
them let's do this one let's see how
many zeros we have we have three six
nine twelve so we want to do again we
start with our largest term that we have
our largest nonzero term in this case
this is going to be the term all with
the left
that's our seven so there's going to be
7.0 one two it's going to be equal to
seven point zero one two times ten to
the what well it's going to be times ten
to the one with this many zeros so how
many things we we had a one here and
then we had one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve zeros
now I want to be very clear you're not
just counting the zeros you're counting
everything after you're counting
everything after this first term right
there so it'd be going to a one followed
by twelve zeros so it's times ten to the
twelfth just like that not too difficult
let's do this one right here so we
thought we go behind our decimal point
we find the first nonzero number that's
our five so it's going to be equal to
five there's nothing to the right of it
so it's five point zero zero if we
wanted to add some precision to it but
it's five times and then how many
numbers to the right or behind to the
right of the decimal do we have we have
one two three four five six seven eight
nine 10 11 12 13 and we have to include
this one 14 so 5 times 10 to the minus
14th power now this number you might
might be a little overkill to write this
in scientific notation but it never
hurts to get the practice so what's the
largest 10 that goes into this well 100
will go into this and you could you
could figure out 100 or 10 squared by
saying okay this is our largest term and
then we have to you can say zeros behind
it because we could say 100 will go into
723 so this is going to be equal to
seven point two three times we could say
times 100 but we want to stay in
scientific notation so we'll write times
10 squared now we have this character
right here what's our first nonzero term
it's that
one right there so it's going to be six
times and then how many terms we have to
the right of the decimal we have only
one so times ten to the minus one and
that makes a lot of sense because that's
essentially equal to 6 divided by 10
because 10 to the minus 1 is 1 over 10
which is 0.6 one more so let me throw
some commas here just to make this a
little bit more a little easier to look
at so let's take our largest value right
there we have our 8 so it's going to be
write a little neater this is going to
be eight point two three eight point two
three we don't have to add the other
stuff because everything else is zero
times 10 to though well we just count
how many terms are after those 8 so we
have one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten it's eight point two
three times ten to the ten I think you
get the idea now it's pretty
straightforward and more than just being
able to calculate this which is a good
skill by itself I want you to understand
why this is the case in hopefully that
last video explained it and if it
doesn't just just multiply this out
literally multiply out eight point two
three times ten to the ten and you will
get this number maybe you could try it
with something smaller than ten to the
ten maybe ten to the fifth and once you
get a different number but you'll have
you'll end up with five digits after the
eight but anyway let me do a couple of
more computation examples let's say we
had let's say we had the numbers point
let me just make something really small
six four and let me make a large number
let's say I have that number and I want
to multiply it I want to multiply it by
let's say I have a really large number
three two I'm just going to throw a
bunch of zeros here don't know when I'm
going to stop let's say I stop there so
this one you could multiply out but it's
you know it's you have to count well
it's a little difficult but let's put it
in a scientific notation one it'll be
easier to represent these numbers and
the hopefully you'll see that the the
multiplication actually gets simplified
as well so this top guy right here what
how can we write him in scientific
notation it would be six point four six
point four times ten to the what one two
three four five six
have to include the six so times 10 to
the minus six and what can this one be
written as this one is going to be three
point two right three point two and then
you count how many digits are after the
three one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten eleven
so 3.2 times 10 to the 11 so if we
multiply these two things this is
equivalent to six let me do it in a
different color this is equivalent to
six point four times ten to the minus
six x times three point two times ten to
the eleventh which we saw in the last
video is equivalent to six point four
times three point two I'm just changing
the order of our multiplication times
ten to the minus six times ten to the
eleventh power and now what will this be
equal to well to do this I don't want to
use a calculator so let's actually let's
just calculate it so six point four
times three point two let's ignore the
decimals for a second we'll worry about
that at the end so 2 times 4 is 8 2
times 6 is 12 nowhere to carry the 1 so
it's just 128 put a zero down there 3
times 4 is 12 carry the 1 3 times 6 is
18
we got a 1 there so it's 192 all right
yeah 192 you add them up you get 8 or 1
plus 9 is 10 carry the 1 you get 2 now
we just have to count the numbers behind
the decimal point we have one number
there we have another number there we
have two numbers behind the decimal
point so you count one two so six point
four times three point two is equal to
20 point four eight so this is going to
be 20 point four eight times 10 to that
we have the same base here so we can
just add the exponents so what's minus
six plus 11 so that's 10 to the fifth
power
right right minus 6 and 11 10 to the
fifth power and so the next question
might say I'm done I've written I've
done the computation and you have and
this is
a valid answer but the next question is
is this in scientific notation and if
you wanted to be a real stickler about
it it's not in scientific notation
because we have something here that
could maybe be simplified a little bit
we could write this let me do it this
way let me divide this by ten so any
number we can multiply and divide by ten
so we could rewrite it this way we could
write one over ten on this side and then
we can multiply times ten on that side
right that shouldn't change the number
if you divide by 10 and multiply by 10
that's just like multiplying by one or
dividing by one so if you divide this
side by ten you get 2.0 for eight and
you multiply that side by ten you get
two times ten to the times ten is just
times ten to the first you can just add
the exponents times 10 to the six and
now if you're a stickler about it this
is good scientific notation right there
right there now I've done a lot of
multiplication let's do some let's do
some division let's do some division
let's divide this guy by that guy so if
we divide if we have 3.2 times 10 to the
11th power divided by six point four
times ten to the minus six what is this
equal to well this is equal to three
point two two over six point four we can
just separate them out because it's
associative so we could we could say
this is its this times 10 to the 11th
over 10 to the minus six right if you
multiply these two things you'll get
that right there so three point two over
six point four this is just equal to 0.5
right 32 is half of 64 or 3.2 is half of
6.4 so this is 0.5 right there and what
is this this is 10 to the 11th over 10
to the minus 6 so when you have
something in the denominator you could
write it this way this is equivalent to
10 to the 11th over 10 to the minus 6 is
equal to 10 to the 11th this is equal
times 10 to the minus 6 to the minus 1
or this is equal to 10 to the 11th times
10 to the 6th and how what did I do just
there this is 1 over 10 to the minus 6
so one over something is just that
something to the negative one power and
then I multiply the exponents you can
think of it that way and so this would
be equal to 10 to the 17th power 10 to
the 17th power or another way to think
about it is if you have one you have the
same bases 10 in this case and you're
dividing the and you're dividing them
you just take the one in the numerator
and you subtract to the exponent the
denominator so it's 11 minus minus 6
which is 11 plus 6 which is equal to 17
so this division problem ended up being
equal to 0.5 0.5 times 10 to the 17th
which is the correct answer but if you
wanted to be a stickler and put into
scientific notation we want something
maybe greater than 1 right here so the
way we can do that let's multiply by 10
on this side let's multiply by 10 on
this side and divide by 10 on this side
or multiply by 1 over 10 remember we're
not changing the number if you multiply
by 10 and divide by 10 we're just doing
it to different parts of the product so
this side is going to become 5 do it in
pink this side is going to become 5
right 10 times 0.5 is 5 times 10 to the
17th divided by 10 that's the same thing
as 10 to the 17th times 10 to the minus
1 right that's 10 to the minus 1 so it's
equal to 10 to the 16th power 10 to the
16th power which is the answer when you
divide these two guys right there so
hopefully these examples have given
filled in all of the Glac gaps or the
uncertain scenarios dealing with
scientific notation if I haven't covered
something feel free to write a comment
on this video or pop me an email